Everyone. Thank you so much for coming and finding your way all
the way to the very end of the convention center.
I appreciate all of you being here.
I have a few housekeeping announcements.
One is that there is a QR code on your screen.
If you're too shy to come up to the mic to ask questions, feel free to send them
in via that QR code.
If you do have questions, please come up to the mic.
This is all being recorded and streamed, so please announce yourself, your name,
your institution, and then ask your question.
So did I forget anything else?
I'm good. Okay.
I feel like he's making signs, but okay.
So
we are going to get started on this
symposium. And this is just
an overview that I put together of the three different talks.
We've been thinking about secreted factors as an
important next hallmark of cancer.
I was delighted when Doug Hanahan was writing his new
updated Hallmarks of Cancer. He did reach out and ask about both
microenvironmental secreted factors as well as things like aging and
macroenvironmental factors. And so you're going to hear three talks
today. One is from Dr. Rishika Perera from
UCSF, who's going to be talking about the autophagy
lysosome system and how this can disrupt
supportive metastatic niches and how she can target those.
You're then going to hear from Dr. Jovisha Bajaj
about temporal changes in secreted metabolites,
and how those are changing. She just had a really fascinating
nature paper on some of these exciting changes that she's seeing.
And then finally, you get stuck hearing from me, and I'm going to tell you a little
bit about our work on aging and the tumor immune
microenvironment in tumor progression.
So
what we're hoping you will take away from this session is that
no tumor is an island. This is something I say all the time.
If we're going to really disrupt this disease and treat this disease,
we need to have a cohesive and think about transformative
approaches. And that's going to include not only the tumor, but also the
microenvironment. And I know I have a ton of microenvironment fans in the
audience because I saw all of you outside.
So without any further ado, Dr. Perera.
You're all sitting over there, so I can't see all your faces.
But anyway, thanks everybody for being here.
There's so many excellent sessions, so we're so grateful that you
come to ours. I'm going to tell you a little bit about our efforts
to think about
the selective vulnerabilities of pancreatic cancer cells as they
migrate from the primary site to metastatic sites,
mostly the liver and the lungs.
Because this is about secreted factors, I'm going to tell you about maybe an
unexpected secreted factor that you may not have thought about in the past.
So,
just for
background, I know many of you here know a lot about pancreatic cancer.
For those of you who may not, these are some of the key features.
I won't go through all the details of this.
I'll highlight some excellent reviews that
have been published by colleagues in the field.
What I'll focus on primarily today has been what we study
in my lab, which is the role of nutrient
scavenging pathways that I'll describe in a little bit more detail, as well as, as
I mentioned, their role during metastatic spread throughout the
body.
So we study these pathways called autophagy,
macropinocytosis, which we broadly refer to as nutrient scavenging
pathways. These are all upregulated in pancreatic ductal
adenocarcinoma, which is the cancer of the pancreas that we focus on in the
lab. It's the most aggressive variant
of pancreas cancer. There's an organ
site-specific session that's at 12:30 today, so I encourage you all to go
if you're interested in this disease and want to learn more.
For the purposes of today, though, I want to highlight the fact that these pathways
are upregulated. This is work done by Alec Kimmelman and several others showing
that a process called autophagy is
constitutively active. This is a process whereby you capture
intracellular material, package it into a double membrane vesicle, and then bring
it to the lysosome for degradation.
Cosimo Commisso, Dafna Bar-Sagi
showed that another scavenging pathway called macropinocytosis is also
upregulated. Captures extracellular components such as
lipids and proteins, and again, packages them, brings it to the lysosome for
degradation. And as you would expect, PDAC cells upregulate lysosomal
biogenesis to
contend with this increased flux of traffic that comes to the
lysosome to be degraded.
So,
some of you may know a lot about the lysosome, some of you may not, but this is a
fascinating organelle that we've spent a lot of our time thinking about in more
detail, primarily because it is a central degradative and metabolic
hub within the cell. Again, it's about 15-fold upregulated.
It's biogenesis in PDAC, and it serves a number of important
roles. It has enzymes within its lumen that's responsible for
breakdown of all macromolecules within a cell.
Proteins, lipids, nucleic acids, sugars.
It has sensors, metabolic sensors that can detect the amount of
luminal nutrients as well as cytoplasmic nutrients.
It has transporters that can exchange these degradation products back with the
cell to fuel bioenergetic and biosynthetic processes.
And signal transducers like the mammalian target or mechanistic
target of rapamycin, an important growth regulator that localizes
to the lysosome in order to be activated and then
transmits signals, proliferative signals from
the lysosomal membrane.So when I started my lab many years ago
now, we were interested in understanding how is the lysosome different in
cancer cells versus
normal cells. And to do this, we used a technique developed in David Sabatini's
lab that allows us to immunoisolate intact lysosomes from
cells that are then amenable to mass spec-based analysis.
I won't go through the details here, but just to say that we can compare
by using proteomics all the proteins that
are captured within lysosomes or the resident proteins that are
specific to this organelle isolated from a tumor cell
versus the same organelle isolated from a non-tumor cell.
So everything on the right-hand side of this volcano plot is proteins
enriched in PDAC lysosomes. Everything on the left are proteins enriched in normal
lysosomes. They fall into two categories, cargoes that are brought from
elsewhere in the cell or outside the cell to be degraded, or
resident proteins that are intrinsic to the lysosome, like those
transporters, like enzymes and so on.
And you can tell from this plot alone that there's a huge difference.
There's things that are very much unique to the cancer context and things that are
unique to the normal context.
Over the years, we've used this technique to understand a lot about how the
lysosome contributes to all these different processes within PDAC
cells, from resistance to therapy, selective degradation of
certain cargoes versus others. And what I want to tell you about
today is related a little bit more to metabolism and
metastasis and how we've been able to take this
technique from isolating lysosomes from 2D cultured cells, which is what we
did traditionally, and translating this to
in vivo tumors. So while there's a lot we can learn by
isolating lysosomes and profiling their content from cells cultured in
2D, we recognize that's not representative of how these tumors grow
in our bodies, right? So Grace Hernandez, who's a graduate student
in my lab, really took on this project, which is very challenging.
How do you go about purifying lysosomes from a tumor growing
within a living organism and specifically from the tumor
epithelia? So what we did as a simple way is
to engineer this tag into mouse PDAC
lines, and then we transplanted them either into the
pancreas. And in the course of this process, Grace
also wanted to understand an important question about how perhaps the lysosome
helps cells to adapt once they're growing into these two different
metastatic sites, the liver and the lung.
So what she did here was to take these KPCL, because it expresses the tag,
or KPC with no tag, inject them orthotopic to
seed the pancreas, intra-splenically to seed the liver, or via tail vein to
seed the lung. She then customized techniques to be able to purify lysosomes
from tumors growing in each of these three different locations.
The proteomics was done in collaboration with Joe Mankus at Dana-Farber.
And this is just to show you the purity of these in vivo LysoIPs that we're now
doing. So here you can see cells expressing the lysotag.
You get purification of lysosome-specific proteins, but all
other organelle markers of other organelles are not there because they get
washed away in the flow-through. Whereas the tumors that don't have the
tag, you really don't purify anything at all.
And then we did the mass spec with Joe. So this is what it looks like.
Tumors isolated from the pancreas, liver, and lung.
We then purify the lysosomes, and you can see a really nice
enrichment of luminal hydrolases.
That tells us the lysosomes are intact.
Tumors that don't have the lysotag, you notice this is pretty clean, so we're not
purifying really anything because there's no tag.
And we can do this successively from all three sites.
From here, we then can start to understand what's common and
unique to the cargoes that are targeted to the lysosome for degradation.
There's a lot of things that are common, some things that are common to the
metastatic sites, some things that are common to one metastatic site
versus another. And I want to take you quickly through them, like some
examples. So MHC class 1 we had shown previously was an
enriched cargo that was targeted for degradation in PDAC.
We can find this in in vivo tumors as well.
We can find other processes like mitochondrial turnover are really
unique to the lung tumors. So the lysosomes are
turning over mitochondria much more efficiently in the lung.
Perhaps this makes sense. This is a more oxygenated environment.
They're more likely to have mitochondrial damage.
And then we see other things that are unique, perhaps to the liver.
So cholesterol transport, we published a paper on this last year,
and then turnover of extracellular matrix and intragrins, which I'll talk
about a little bit more later on. So Grace had to make an executive
decision. Of all these proteins, how do you pick one thing
and build a thesis project? Not an easy thing to do,
but she did it. And she decided to focus not on the cargoes,
but on the resident proteins, the lysosomal resident proteins.
So most of them are the same. Lysosomes are lysosomes, right?
So there's transporters, there's enzymes, and so on.
But she noticed one lysosomal enzyme that was different, and it's called
legumen. It's a asparaginyl endopeptidase, broadly expressed,
well-characterized, crystal structure is known, and the substrates
are also fairly well-characterized.
Matrix proteins, MMPs, cathepsins, and so on.
So we went back and looked at our tumors, and you can clearly see that--
so I should say, sorry, going back.
This was really down-regulated in the pancreas or de-enriched,
but then high in the liver versus the lung.
So that was also a really interesting aspect for us to understand.
Why was this lysosomal enzyme being enriched in the metastatic
lesion? So we went back and stained for legumen.
This is in blue. What you'll notice in the tumor
epithelia, which is here, you really don't see a lot of legumen at
all. There's lots in the stroma. These macrophages express it, fibroblasts
express it, but the tumor epithelia does not when it's growing in the
pancreas. These same cells, when transplanted in the
liver, thoughupregulate legumen.
Now you can see there's a lot of legumen in the tumor epithelia, as well as in the
surrounding tumor. Now, if we just did a whole cell lysate of the tumor, we'd never
see this difference because the external tumor
extrinsic legumen is very high.
So we also looked at patient PDAC. So this is primary PDAC on the
top, liver metastasis on the bottom.
And again, you see very high levels of legumen, much higher in the
liver mets relative to the primary.
So what does this mean? Is this functionally important?
So what she did was to knock out legumen
in our KPC lines, no defect in
vitro proliferation. And then what she did was to
orthotopically transplant them back into the pancreas or via
intrasplenic injection into the liver. And she noticed something really striking.
So loss of legumen doesn't lead to any change in the ability of the
tumors to grow in the pancreas.
Tumor weights are the same. But those same cells injected back into the
liver, what she noticed is their ability to grow was severely compromised.
So this is overall tumor weight, and this is what the histology looks like.
So normally they grow really fine.
They grow well in the pancreas as well, but the same cells transplanted to grow in
the liver have a compromised ability to grow.
So this suggested that a lysosomal enzyme shows selective
dependency, is selectively required for growth in the liver, but not in
the pancreas.
So what happened? So it's a lysosomal enzyme.
We looked at the lysosomal morphology to begin with.
Usually when you lose one of these enzymes, you start to see lysosomal defects,
which is characterized by an increase in lysosomal size as things start to
accumulate and not get digested. And you can see that here
compared to the control, our lysosomes start to look big and
bloated.
We also know what legumen does. So I'm going to take you through this a little
slowly. So these are lysosomal cathepsins.
These are other proteases that are also present within the lysosome.
And what legumen's role is, is to be able to facilitate their
maturation from this single chain form to a two chain form.
It removes a
small peptide, so it runs at a lower molecular weight.
And this is thought to be the most mature form of cathepsins.
Now, cathepsins are responsible for digestion of
proteins that are brought to the lysosome for degradation.
So this is what it looks like on a western blot.
So normally this is the pro form of cathepsin L.
It's
matured into this two chain form. So this version here.
If you lose legumen, you see loss of this
maturation process and accumulation of this intermediate single
chain form. So that's one of the main roles of legumen in the lysosome
is to not only digest its own substrates, but several of its
substrates are these cathepsins.
So this is dependent on legumen activity.
Again,
this is the mature form of cathepsin.
If you lose it, you get accumulation of this single chain form.
In the knockout cells, if we put back wild type, you can see it
rescues the phenotype. If you put two catalytically dead variants, you can see
that now we don't rescue the phenotype.
So this is very much dependent on legumen catalytic activity. Okay.
Cathepsin activity is reduced. It's not completely blocked because
the single chain form still retains some activity.
What's thought is that the substrate selectivity starts to change.
So this is where it gets very interesting and where secretion becomes
interesting, as is the theme of this session.
So what's known is that when you have lysosomal defects,
such as increases in size, as well as the accumulation of
immature cathepsins, in order to sustain
viability of the cells and to start to get rid of all this accumulated material
that's not being digested properly, the lysosomes can undergo a process called
exocytosis. They fuse with the membrane and then release all of their
material out into the extracellular space, including these cathepsins and
hydrolases.
So we wanted to see whether this was happening.
So we took isogenic lines of primary PDAC and the matched liver met
that we isolated from a mouse, a genetically engineered mouse that develops
PDAC spontaneously. And then we took the supernatant of these
cells and then performed a western blot for cathepsin L.
So this is the single chain form because the mature form never
gets secreted. It's only the single chain form that does.
You'll notice that in the primary, we really don't see much single
chain being secreted at all. In the liver met, it's even
less. But if you lose cathepsin, lose legumen,
and you accumulate this single chain form, this intermediate
step, now you start to see a lot more of the cathepsins being
secreted into extracellular space.
Now, this poses an interesting question.
What are the substrates that this cathepsin is now starting to digest that could
be different from what it would digest if it was natively within the lysosome
within cells?
And there's a lot of work that has been done by Joanna Joyce and others in the
field that have shown that these cathepsins can actually facilitate the
breakdown and remodeling of extracellular matrix proteins like
collagens.
So we asked whether this was true. We did an in vitro assay first
where we plated cells with fluorescent collagen.
We then placed our tumor cells on top, either the
wild type cells or the legumen knockout cells, and then monitored them for
seven days to look at the level of collagen breakdown.
In one arm of the experiment, we added a cathepsin inhibitor,
E64d, on two days, on day three and day five.
So this is what it looks like. So on day three, you can see that the
level of collagen is the same because it's plated in the same way,
regardless of whether there's the normal cells or the control cells versus the
legumen knockout cells. Over time, it's at day seven, you'll notice
that the levels of collagen
are decreased in the knockout cells.
We think it's because digestion and remodeling is...
higher when we have increased secretion of these cathepsins.
And this is rescued if you add the E64d inhibitor, which is a
selective inhibitor of these cathepsins, suggesting that the
secretion of the cathepsins are remodeling
or digesting collagen at a higher level than the
normal cells.
Now, is this true in vivo? So we took our legumen knockout
tumors versus our control tumors.
We did mass spec-based proteomics, and we noticed that in the knockout
tumors, there's a huge reduction of all the collagens,
type I collagens, type V, type III, and so on.
This is what it looks like. So these tumors have
lots and lots of collagen in the control setting, but in the knockout
tumors, which are controlled for overall size, you see that
there's really not a lot of collagen at all. Right?
We don't think this is because of a defect in deposition.
The deposition of collagen is mostly done by the fibroblasts.
We think this is a reflection of the tumor cells secreting something that
they normally shouldn't, that is breaking down collagen in a
way that is not conducive to establishment of a
niche that allows them to grow effectively.
This is not the case in the primary tumor.
As I mentioned before, the primary tumors grow perfectly fine with loss of
legumen. And this is because these tumors are able,
or the
niche environment is established well, and the collagen is
modeled in a way that's advantageous for tumor growth.
Okay. So, and this is all unpublished data,
still not even bioRxiv. We're still work in
progress. So there's a lot of experts in the field here who really
have done very important work in the extracellular matrix.
I'd love to hear from them and hear your advice.
But what we think is happening is in wild type legumen
settings,
the ability to process cathepsins
efficiently to the two-chain form allows for
digestion of lysosome-delivered material
efficiently.
In the context of legumen knockout, this
upregulation or accumulation of this intermediate single-chain
legumen form causes a lysosomal defect that leads
to lysosomal exocytosis and release of these
single-chain cathepsins that then, when they shouldn't, start to
break down material within the extracellular space
that doesn't allow for, or causes a
failure to establish an appropriate niche for these cells to seed
and colonize efficiently.
And that is specific to the liver and not to the pancreas.
We don't quite know why, but this is where we are.
So
I want to thank all the people that did the work.
So Grace, this is all the work of a graduate student, Grace Hernandez,
with help from Val Weaver, Matt Kudys, Charlie Craig,
Joe, obviously, who was really essential and
played a large role in doing all the lysosomal proteomics from these three
different tumor compartments. So with that, thank you very
much for your attention. Happy to take any questions.
Please introduce yourself. And
thank you. Martin.
Hi, Ruchika. As always, a model of clarity, really beautiful presentation.
So since I think of everything through the lens of RAS-
Yes
... I'm always reminded that the very first RAS-regulated gene that was ever
discovered is actually cathepsin L.
Yeah.
And I'm wondering, have you ever looked to see whether legumen is actually a
RAS-regulated gene? Is there a connection here for a sort of broader
program of regulation of this system-
Yeah
... by the driver oncoprotein in the system?
Yeah. We have to do that. It's a really good point.
We actually went in a slightly different direction.
We thought lysosomal proteins are usually regulated by the MITTFE
family of transcription factors. Legumen is not.
So it's very possible that it is regulated via a RAS signaling
pathway, and then the exact transcription factor, we're not sure who it is
as yet.
Yeah.
Great point.
Thank you.
Florian.
Florian Karath from Moffitt Cancer Center. Great talk as always, Ruchika.
But I'm curious about the expression of legumen
or the lack of expression of legumen in the primary tumor.
I know.
Is that actually required for them to grow and maybe recruit the-
Yeah
... stromal components? Have you tried enforcing legumen expression-
Yes
... in the primary tumor and see if that inhibits growth but
promotes metastasis?
Yeah. Excellent point. We're doing that now.
All right. Thank you.
Yes.
Aaron Andrachek, Michigan State University.
So normally your liver metastases are desmoplastic for PDAC.
With your legumen knockout, is that maintained?
So, no. So we lose some of the
collagen, for sure. The ECM changes quite significantly.
We looked at whether fibroblasts abundance changed. That doesn't.
Immune signatures don't change. There's still macrophages, some level of
macrophage and T cell infiltration.
So
I don't know whether the cell types change, but the ECM changes.
The matrix proteins change. Yeah.
Yes, Klaus.
Lovely talk. Klaus Jogault in Manchester.
So have you looked at integrin expression and stiffness
sensing in a metastatic environment?
I knew you would ask me this question.
You're welcome.
Yes. So with Val Weaver, we're using her stiff
maps approach. And as would be expected, the
stiffness does change when the collagen changes so dramatically.
Yeah.
And with her, because we have the proteomics, we can look at the integrins,
although that's whole proteomics of all the cell types within the
tumor, so it doesn't necessarily specifically point to an integrin in the
tumor epithelia, but we'd love to be able to know that that does change a lot.
Yeah, that'd be awesome. Thanks.
Yeah. Great. Hi. Yes.
Annette Heirs, Weizmann Institute. Great talk.
So I'm always fascinated by organ specificity, which you
showed really nicely, and I'm wondering about the lungs.
Yes.
Because fibrosis and-
Yes
... ECM were shown in many, many studies to be important for lung metastasis.
Yes.
So I'm wondering if you have any thoughts about ligamen, and why is it not-
Yeah
... important in lungs?
So I didn't show the lung data, but the lung is in between,
so is somewhat dependent on ligamen, but not to the
level that the liver is, but is not like the pancreas where
you can completely dispense of it. So, it's strange, right?
Ligamen is there in the
lysosomes or is detected in both the liver and the lung mets,
not in the pancreas,
but its dependency seems to be that much more important
for the liver,
less so in the lung, but more than in the primary.
We don't know why.
Interesting.
Yeah. Yes.
Beautiful talk as always, Rushika.
So I'll follow up on Annette's question and another tiny
question. So do you think that macrophages have anything to do with the difference
between the lung and the liver?
Yeah.
And then also, do you see differences, maybe I missed this, in
autophagy that-
Oh
... might be connected to-
Right
... what you see?
Excellent point. This is at the start of the paper, and I
didn't talk about it, but we started by asking this fundamental
question of whether autophagy and lysosomes are different even in
metastatic lesions versus primary, and it's not. It's still high.
So that's not a difference.
Related to the macrophage question, I think the simplest thing that we did
was to ask whether the abundance of macrophages, their state,
and whether they might be responsible for
secreting any kind of collagens might be different, and there isn't.
So it's very likely that the fibroblast or
whoever's depositing the collagen, they're doing that efficiently
as they normally would. We've done some conditioned media
experiments, all kinds of in vitro assays and things
like that.
But it's more likely to be the remodeling that happens
to be the more significant phenotype here, rather than the
deposition. Yeah.
Yes.
Hi, my name's Heather McGee from City of Hope.
This is brilliant work.
Oh.
And my question is,
since cathepsins can activate granzyme B-
Yeah
... which is produced by CD8 T cells-
Right
... natural killer cells.
So natural killer cells are enriched in the liver.
Do you think that possibly the differences that you're seeing are due
to cathepsin's ability to activate granzyme B from NK cells in
the liver and induce an antitumor immune response specifically in the liver
as opposed to the other organ?
I'm going to give you a really short answer. We don't know. Very good point.
Can we collaborate on this?
Sure. Let's talk.
I'm down.
I'm not going to ask the question because Sashi is showing.
Okay.
But the person that spoke before the last person, for the
recording, that was Ruth Shuval from the Weizmann.
Okay. Thanks, everybody.
Thanks, Eti. I appreciate that. All right, so next up we have Jivisha
Bajaj from University of Rochester.
Okay.
I'm going to start by thanking the organizers for inviting me here.
This is my very first AACR. I'm super excited to be here.
And also all of you for coming to my talk.
So
I have nothing to disclose. My lab is primarily interested in
acute myeloid leukemias, which are characterized by this
accumulation of immature blast cells,
both in the peripheral blood and in the bone marrow.
These cancers typically arise from mutations in the hematopoietic stem
progenitor cells. They can arise de novo or
progress from indolent diseases such as myelodysplastic
syndromes.
Despite the advent of targeted therapy in the last few years, such as
venetoclax and FLT3 ITD specific inhibitors,
the overall survival outcomes for these diseases remain fairly
dismal, highlighting a need to think outside the box and not
just target the mutations themselves.
We have been greatly inspired by the large body of work in solid
tumors showing how important the fibroblasts and the stromal
microenvironment can be in promoting disease progression.
So really, my lab is focusing on how interactions with these
non-immune stromal cells can play a role in AML
progression.
So we are often asked, why should someone care about the
microenvironment in a cancer which is fluid? It's everywhere.
It is in the blood. It's in the marrow. What really is the microenvironment?
To answer that question, we go back and ask, where do these cancers
arise? So a large body of literature,
primarily driven by pioneering work from the labs
of Sean Morrison, David Scadden, Paul Frenette, and many others,
have shown that the non-immune stromal cell niche, such as
mesenchymal stromal cells, the osteoblasts, as well as
endothelial cells, provide signals and support for the most
primitive hematopoietic stem cells.
So this gives us some rationale for actually studying whether the same
cells can now support the leukemia cells,
and at least in the beginning, when they're actually in this niche, which is also
occupied by the normal, non-mutant cells.
Using imaging-based studies,
several groups have shown a remodeling of the bone marrow
niche in murine models, and this includes
increased ECM deposition,
loss in the integrity of blood vessels.And as well
as neuropathies in some cases,
suggesting that the cancer is indeed actively, even in the context of
leukemia, remodeling specifically the bone marrow niche.
In addition to the remodeling itself, what we're interested in is the signals that
can support disease progression.
These can be cell-cell interactions, adhesive interactions,
or secretory factors.
My initial work as a postdoctoral fellow in Tanush Taraya's
lab used candidate-based approaches to look at
cell-cell interactions and adhesion.
And what we found is that CD98 and
tetraspanin-3 mediated adhesion signals can be
important for sustaining the leukemia stem cell populations, as
well as for promoting aggressive disease outcomes.
Moving on from there, we wanted to take a more
higher-level view of the secreted factors that could be coming from the stromal
components. And to do that, we leveraged single-cell RNA
sequencing.
One of the problems in the field of leukemia for long has been that most models
that we have used in the past have required conditioning of the bone marrow
to actually allow the engraftment of the leukemia cells.
But now we have models that can grow in
immunocompetent mice without the need of
niche-destroying
techniques. So we can
take leukemia stem progenitor cells, engraft them in immunocompetent
mice, and then isolate the CD45 negative Ter119
negative bone marrow stromal cells from
these mice at different time points.
The models that we use are very aggressive.
Between two to three weeks is the lifespan of the mice with these cancers, and
these are the time points on the survival curve highlighted here.
So our single-cell sequencing
analysis does identify many populations that are seen in the
normal bone marrow niche. These analyses are leveraging some newer
studies in the last five to six years of the bone marrow microenvironment,
which have developed the pipelines for analyzing these data.
These include the subpopulations of endothelial cells,
multiple different fibroblast populations, which we hope to study in the future,
but we are still understanding how to separate them out and work with them in
vitro. The MSCs, and as well as the
osteo-associated populations.
But interestingly, over time, what we see is that these populations do change.
The cancer is changing the transcriptional profile, which is very obvious
here in the arteriolar endothelial and the mesenchymal cells,
suggesting that the populations are perhaps secreting different factors
or just physically changing.
So a gene expression profiling and pathway analysis
identifies that a downregulation of osteo
lineage differentiation in MSCs, which is perhaps
reminiscent of what happens in people with AML who often present
with osteopenias.
We also see downregulation of adhesion in the
endothelial cells. This would perhaps explain the leaky blood
vessels seen by Dominic Bonnet's group and others using in vivo imaging techniques.
So now moving on to what are the factors that are secreted from these cells,
and how are they actually being used by the cancer?
As you can imagine, there are hundreds or thousands of different factors that
we can identify. How does one go about narrowing down on what is
actually important for the cancer cell growth?
To address that, we switched to the cancer cells perspective and looked
at the cell surface receptors that are being enriched and expressed on the
leukemia cells themselves because they are perhaps the first ones that are going to
be responding to the signals from the niche.
So to this end, we carried out an RNA-seq analysis
from healthy donor bone marrow C34-positive cells,
as well as
patient samples from two different models of aggressive leukemia, acute myeloid
leukemia, as well as the blast crisis phase of chronic myeloid
leukemia. They are pathophysiologically very similar diseases, and
at their most aggressive phases, they are
often treated similarly in the clinic.
And this work was done in collaboration with Craig Jordan in
Colorado.
What we find now from here is differentially expressed genes,
which we can then
cross to publicly available cell surface atlases to narrow
down on the cell surface proteins, as well as a genome-wide in
vivo CRISPR screen that we did, which has identified
dependencies of the leukemia cells in vivo.
And we can now identify signals that are unique to AML,
to BCCML, or both, and then use tools like
NicheNet to develop these maps, which can now show
crosstalk between receptors on the leukemia cells and the ligands
being secreted or signals coming from the different stromal
populations. While we did not do the immune niche ourselves, we
were able to leverage data from patient AML immune
microenvironment from Janis Ifantidis' group, which was very
helpful.
These kind of maps did identify interactions that have previously been
reported in literature validating our approach in
principle. And the two that I'm going to talk about today
are the SLC66A6 and LDLR, primarily
because those were the ones which were strongly associated with poor prognosis in
patient samples in DCGA data.
So starting with SLC66A6, it is the taurine transporter.
Taurine itself is a non-essential amino acid, which
can be obtained by diet, is also synthesized by the liver,
primarily from cysteine.And what we found, which was very
interesting, was that the expression of CDO1
was unique, was one, was shocking to see it was present in the bone marrow, and
second, it was uniquely restricted to the osteolineage cells,
suggesting that these perhaps could be a local source of taurine in the bone marrow
niche.
So our in vitro experiments where we take MSCs and
induce osteogenic differentiation, what we see is that they do indeed secrete
taurine in the media as soon as we induce osteogenic differentiation.
Consistent with this, there's increased taurine in the bone marrow plasma of
mice with leukemia compared to the ones which don't have cancer.
Before doing any functional studies, we wanted to ensure that this was not
something which was restricted or unique to the mouse bone marrow niche.
So we collaborated with our physician colleagues to get patient samples,
biopsies from patients who have progressive disease,
like MDS to AML, and then from AML diagnosis to
relapse. And in most cases, we do
see a striking increase in the synthesis of CDO1
in the patient as the disease progresses in patients,
suggesting that this is perhaps a signal that is conserved between
mice and human.
To functionally test the requirement of
taurine being produced by the stromal cells, we
use in vitro co-culture assays. We can do these with mice.
I'm going to show you data which we have done with human.
So we established mesenchymal stromal cell cultures from bone marrow
of patients,
transduced them with shRNAs targeting either control or CDO1,
and after promoting differentiation, we add leukemia cells now from
the peripheral blood of the same patient and look at the support and
growth of these cells over time.
And what you can see here is that cells that are growing in an environment, an
MSC osteolineage environment that does not express CDO are not able to
survive well, and neither are they able to form colonies, suggesting
that this taurine from the local niche is perhaps playing a functional role in
supporting the leukemia cells.
So taurine in the bone marrow is perhaps a very small source.
Much of it is diet or liver. So we wanted to see in vivo
whether inhibiting taurine synthesis in the MSCs or the
osteolineage cells could actually have any impact at all on disease progression.
So to do that, we developed a CDO1 floxed mouse, crossed it to the
MSC specific Prx1-Cre, and used these mice as
recipients of leukemia.
As you can see here, we do indeed see that inhibiting CDO1
expression in MSC lineage specifically can
improve survival outcomes, at least in part,
suggesting that the locally produced taurine is perhaps indeed playing a role in
disease progression.
I'm going to switch gears and now talk about the transporter
itself and its function in promoting disease growth.
So what I did not mention before is that we do not see CDO1
expression in the leukemia cells themselves.
There's barely any RNA expressed, so they're
primarily relying on taurine coming from outside.
We
obtained a taurine transporter knockout mouse from a collaborator in Japan and
used these now to model cancers
using multiple different oncogenes.
And in every case that we tested, we see that
the genetic loss of the taurine transporter can improve survival outcomes
dramatically in many cases,
suggesting that inhibiting this gene may be of value.
But to actually test if this was the case in patient samples, we used
shRNA-based approaches. So we get primary human patient AML
samples or donor-derived human
HSPCs, transduce them with shRNAs
now targeting the taurine transporter, and
look at their growth in vivo in immunodeficient mice.
Now, this is data from multiple different samples. There's huge heterogeneity.
These samples really are not always engraftable, and even when they do,
there's heterogeneity in the way they do it because they're primary samples.
But despite that, we do see a strong impact on the growth
of the leukemia cells when their expression of
the taurine transporter is knocked down.
However, this is not the case in the normal 34 positive cells,
suggesting that there may be a therapeutic window for targeting
this particular transporter in this disease.
But which subtype would one want to target it in?
Just looking at expression, we don't really see preferential expression based on
mutation profile in the patient data sets.
But what we do see is that high expression is linked
to venetoclax resistance. So venetoclax has recently become
standard of care for AML, but resistance has been
associated-- There are newer and newer studies that monocytic cell lineage
fate, as well as RAS mutations, can promote resistance to venetoclax.
I'm just showing you the BTML data, but we have done this across multiple
cohorts of patients, and we see consistent high
expression in resistant phenotype, resistant AML.
Using small molecules, and these are experimental small molecule inhibitors,
we can show is that blocking the taurine
transporter can synergize with venetoclax in vitro, suggesting it
would be of value to develop these further such that they are efficacious in
vivo.
I'm going to quickly walk over the mechanisms that what is happening, what is
taurine really doing to leukemia cells.
This took us on a journey where we learned from many of our collaborators
about metabolism, and we're still learning.
So what we first did was that we isolated-- We
carried out metabolomic analysis because taurine is a metabolite.
And in addition to taurine itself, what we see is a
striking downregulation of glycolysis-associated
metabolites.Which also reflects
in Seahorse assays. And
it appears to be functional because we can rescue the phenotype
by bypassing glycolysis and introducing pyruvate, at least partially in
our in vitro systems, or sodium acetate.
But the problem really was that we did 13C taurine tracing and never
really saw it go anywhere, and we were really confused for the longest time with
what exactly it was doing. So we did an RNA seq, and
we saw transcriptional downregulation of glycolysis-related genes,
which was even more confusing because we didn't know how taurine, a metabolite,
could actually be regulating something at a transcriptional level.
And then what we noticed was that it was actually strikingly
down-regulating mTOR, which has been linked to glycolysis in
the past. So we do see downregulation of the
mTOR pathway, both by Western blot as well as phosphoproteomics.
And using rapamycin shows the
wild-type cells grown in the presence of rapamycin are unable to grow very well,
and this has been done in the past in multiple different AML models.
But more importantly, rapamycin could not add to the phenotype of the
taurine transporter null cells, suggesting that it was indeed downstream.
Rushika elegantly presented work on the mTOR and
lysosomal location, and we tried multiple ways of rescuing this.
But the only way we could really do it was by constitutively
expressing the mutants of Rag and Rheb,
which can promote lysosomal mTOR
localization and activation, suggesting that this is perhaps one
way that taurine is regulating mTOR
signaling. There are definitely missing pieces in between which we are trying to
work them out.
So to just quickly summarize this part of my talk, what I've shown you is that
taurine is produced locally in the bone marrow
stroma by the oste 선in cells, where it can be taken up by the taurine
transporter expressed on the leukemia cells, which then
uses it to activate the mTOR signaling and thus
promote
the growth of cancer.
In the last two or three minutes, I'm going to talk about some of our new work
on the other transporter that was linked with poor
progression, LDLR.
I'm going to specifically focus on its ligand, one of its major ligands,
which is apolipoprotein E. And ApoE,
we do see ApoE expression. Unlike CDO, it's not really restricted to any
population, but it is the highest in the mesenchymal stromal
cells.
ApoE is very famous as a
Alzheimer's-related protein. So
mice do not express different isoforms, but humans have single nucleotide
polymorphisms where ApoE4 is very
strongly linked with a high risk of Alzheimer's disease and
ApoE2 is protective. However, we don't really
know its role in the context of leukemias, and this is what we set
out to study.
So what we did was we used ApoE knockout mice because there are so many tools
now available because of the interest in the Alzheimer's field.
And now we use these as recipients for wild-type leukemia
cells and did a survival analysis.
As you can see here,
the knockout leukemia really doesn't grow well in the absence of
microenvironmental ApoE, suggesting that it may also be playing a role
in sustaining this particular disease.
To look at isoform specificity, we have now started working with our
clinical colleagues to establish cultures.
Sorry, before I do that, I just want to mention that in the humans,
this is data from a human bone marrow
stromal cells where the restriction here
is primarily restricted to the MSC population, unlike the mouse, where it's more
broadly expressed.
So we now have worked with the clinical colleagues to get more
samples and have made MSC cultures with patient
samples and then used ApoE shRNAs to knock it down, and again,
added back peripheral blood AML cells from the same patient and done viability
assays. And in this case also, we see that the
MSCs are not able to really support leukemia cells if their
ability to express or make ApoE is knocked down.
We can genotype these patients, and we are now expanding this cohort to
understand whether it is restricted to one particular subtype of
ApoE or broadly across
all and it doesn't matter what the genotype is.
ApoE primarily transports lipids, so we are
working with, and we know really even less about lipidomics than we do about
metabolomics, so working with Dr.
Gina De Nicola to figure out what ApoE is doing and what lipids
it may be bringing in. Sorry.
So I'm going to stop here by summarizing, saying that adhesive interactions as well
as secretory factors from the bone marrow niche can play a role
in leukemia progression, and these may represent new
therapeutic vulnerabilities of these diseases.
I'm going to stop by acknowledging my lab, our many, many
collaborators, wonderful collaborators, without whom we couldn't have done much of
what we do, and our funding sources. Thank you.
Questions?
So I'll start while we're waiting for people to come up to the mic.
I'm curious to know, when you look at the patient data, are you
seeing any big macroenvironmental changes in body mass
index, age, those kind of factors?
That's actually a great question because we are just using samples, and
because they are so de-identified, we have not been able to go
back and get... But this is something we are trying to build into our IRB
protocols, and we get serial samples from the pathologist
versus from the hem/onc doctors that if there's a way to actually link the
samples, because we are so good at de-identifying them that we are not
-But no, we are definitely working on that.
And also diet, because that's something that we are very curious about, but it
has been more challenging than I thought it would be to go back and get that kind
of information from the patients. But no, thank you for the question.
Thank you.
Well, thank you so much for-
Go ahead. Oh, I think Ettie has a question.
Oh, there's one?
Yes.
Do you know of any evidence of changes in taurine in
any other microenvironment?
We have only looked at the leukemia samples.
We have also now started to look at patients with leukemia and disease progression
in the bone marrow plasma. For the leukemia, we haven't really
looked at any other niche because we are starting with the home, but that's a great
question.
I think we saw them in the amino acid signatures in the pancreas.
I'm almost sure.
Oh, wow. That's good to know. Thank you for that. I will go back and check.
And that was Ettie Kutkierman from Fox Chase.
Yeah. Thank you.
Thank you.
Sorry, Ettie, I had to do that.
No, you're fine.
So, good morning again, everyone.
I'm going to talk to you today about aging and cancer and the intersection
of those two. And the reason we're so interested in cancer, many of
you have seen this slide from me before, is that cancer is a disease of
aging. For every 100 people diagnosed with cancer, over 90% of them will be
over the age of 50.
And this is a growing public health burden because as
we move forward with all sorts of treatments and vaccines,
our population is consistently aging.
And by 2050, we expect almost a third of our
population to be in the age range that is frequently diagnosed with
cancer. This is also the age range in which there is some of the
highest mortality for cancer as well.
Our work is really focused on trying to understand what is happening at the local
microenvironmental level during aging.
And we focused a lot on fibroblast populations, what
those secrete,
and how that impacts not only the signaling
within tumor cells, but also the biophysical matrices on which they
sit. And we're also interested not just in the tumor cells, but also in
other cell types such as endothelial and immune cells, and you'll hear me touch on
all of these throughout this talk.
Over the years, we've found that aging affects multiple different aspects of
tumor progression, from therapy resistance to angiogenesis, metabolism,
the immune microenvironment, metastasis, and dormancy, which I'll talk
about a little bit today.
So our mouse models have focused on mice that are 8 to 10 weeks
old when they are young, and 12 to 18 months old
when they are older. We've looked at several different mouse models in
melanoma. Work done in my lab by Dr.
Dan Sobranski, when he was a fellow with me, has also looked at
multiple different mouse models of pancreatic cancer.
In melanoma, what we see is that as tumors grow in young and aged mice,
they actually grow much faster in young mice
than they do in old mice, but they metastasize far more
effectively in the aged mice.
We have also shown that it's not just age, it's also sex. When Dr.
Yash Chhabra was a fellow with me, he had a
beautiful set of work that he now pursues in his own lab at Fox Chase,
where he showed that
male and female fibroblasts age very differently and have very different
effects on tumor cells,
allowing where the male fibroblasts create an
environment where the tumor cells within those environments become more
resistant to therapy.
What we have seen is that overall, if a patient is diagnosed with a
melanoma when they are very young, they are likely to take a much longer time to
develop a distal metastasis. This is a graph for lung metastases.
But if they are diagnosed over the age of 60, the progression to
metastases is much faster. Which led us to think about tumor
dormancy, because we figured that these tumor cells had already
probably seeded those distant sites, but were just lying there dormant for some
time. And I asked my new best friend, Google Gemini, to make
me
a little picture and compare tumor dormancy to the myth of Sleeping Beauty.
And if all of you cast your mind back and think about Sleeping Beauty, she slept
for 100 years covered by this sort of protective hedge
of thorns, which I forgot and Google reminded me of.
And then was eventually awakened by the kiss of a prince
and was allowed to thrive and grow afterwards.
So a dormant tumor cell does something very similar.
It sits there in this sort of protective matrix that's secreted by
fibroblasts and is sort of kept in check by these enchanted
spells that are immune cells.
And what we're beginning to understand is that they need this
prince's kiss to awaken, if you will.
So when Mitch Fain was in my lab, he's also now a PI.
He's speaking in the next session in ballroom six, chaired by Neda Erez.
So go check out his amazing work that he's doing in his own lab.
He took tumor cells, injected them into the skin of mice, and then he waited three
weeks, took the lungs of these mice, and asked what happened to these
cells. And we see that in young and aged mice, these tumor cells, which are these
little red cells that I've highlighted here, they're tagged with mCherry.
They're just kind of sitting there in both the young and aged lungs.
They're not growing out very rapidly.
But if Mitch waits just a couple more weeks and takes those lungs, he sees that in
the aged lungs, they've grown very rapidly into
large overt colonies.So we were very
interested to know what was the prince's kiss that was making these tumor cells
come out of this dormancy. And so we looked at the
secreted changes in the young and aged lung fibroblasts, identified a few
that we thought were interesting, and of
course, if any of you went to Catholic school and you danced too close to
a boy, you'd meet this lady who would shake her stick at you, and so that's who we
aspire to be, and we're trying to disrupt this prince's kiss.
And so Mitch took an antibody to SFRP1, which is
one of the secreted factors in the lung microenvironment by aged
lung fibroblasts. And he gave those tumors a few weeks to
disseminate for that initial dissemination, and then when he treats the mice with
this antibody against SFRP1, you see that these tumors don't
grow out anymore in the aged lung. So this was all
very exciting and very interesting.
But we also wanted to know what else was going on in that aged tumor
microenvironment and how the immune system was playing a role.
So this is work that has been picked up by Fang Huang, who's currently a
postdoctoral fellow in the lab. And, what Fang has done is to
take
the lungs of young and aged mice, both naive mice and then
mice that have tumors in their skin.
He's then isolated fibroblasts from those lungs and asked what happens to
them. What we see quite consistently is that fibroblasts
isolated from the lungs of aged tumor-bearing mice,
behave very differently from all the other conditions.
They grow faster,
they are more motile in scratch assays,
they have less markers of senescence,
and they also respond to melanoma cell-secreted factors,
whereas fibroblasts from young lungs or even aged naive
lungs do not. So if Fang takes melanoma cells and he
plates them in the bottom of a Transwell, plates fibroblasts on top of the
Transwell and asks what happens, he sees that the fibroblasts themselves
become more motile and more invasive in the presence of melanoma cells,
but only for those from the aged tumor-bearing mice.
They are also less senescent, they're more proliferative,
and they start to secrete different factors as well.
So what he sees is that these aged lung fibroblasts, again,
specifically from aged tumor-bearing mice, secrete factors that are
involved in the recruitment of myeloid-derived suppressor cells,
things like CXCL1, arginase 1, et cetera.
And he can also confirm this in human data sets, I think this one is
from Chris Marine's lab, and show that the aged
fibroblasts in the human CAFs in melanoma are
secreting similar factors.
He then reconfirmed those in his own fibroblasts,
both in the normal and in the aged tumor-bearing fibroblasts.
He sees that again, only in the fibroblasts from aged tumor-bearing
mice, he sees an increase in CXCL1.
We do not see that in naive mice, in
patients who are healthy, but we do again see this in
patients who have cancer.
He also noted that the spleens in aged tumor-bearing mice are
enlarged, and they are full of myeloid-derived suppressor cells.
He also noticed that in the lungs,
the lungs from, again, aged tumor-bearing mice, have
far more MDSCs than those from either young tumor-bearing mice or
naive mice, and that there is a
tend towards a decrease in the T cells as well.
This is also true in the circulating PBMCs, where there's an
increase in myeloid-derived suppressor cells and a decrease in T cells.
So Fang was very curious to know what the signals were between the fibroblasts
and the immune cells. Oh, I'm
sorry. He also showed that these myeloid-derived suppressor cells were functional.
They're more invasive
when exposed to conditioned media from aged
tumor-bearing mice. They're more able to suppress T cells and more
likely to expand.
When he looks at this data
in his human databases, again, he
also sees that there is a decrease in the T cells.
And so he asked the question, "Are the T cells themselves also
different in these young and aged lungs?" So he did what I thought was a really
cool experiment, completely unguided by me, where he took
his tumor cells and he grew them either with
fibroblasts,
that were from the aged tumor-bearing mice or
without fibroblasts. And, he then takes
his T cells that he's isolated from either young or aged mice,
and he puts them into the system. And I think what you can see quite
nicely is that in the presence of the aged fibroblasts, the tumors grow very
rapidly in these spheroid cultures.
If he treats them with PBMCs from young mice,
they are less likely to grow and to invade.
But if he treats them with PBMCs from aged mice, those PBMCs are far
less effective at keeping those spheroids in check.
So, Fang is continuing to explore all of this.
Almost everything I'm showing you today is unpublished and somewhat preliminary
data.
And so what he has found so far is that melanoma cells
themselves, can secrete factors that preferably promote
the activation of aged lung fibroblasts
specifically, and that these melanoma cell-induced secretomic
changes in the aged lung fibroblasts can enhance the recruitment and
function of myeloid-derived suppressor cells.
We know, both from Mitch's work, work in the 10 years
preceding that, and current work in the lab, that non-canonical Wnt signaling
is driving a lot of the dissemination, whereas canonical Wnt
signaling is driving a lot of the proliferation and reactivation of these tumor
cells.We're also very interested in what's happening in brain
metastases. So melanoma is one of a handful of cancers that
metastasizes to the brain, and just like the lung
metastases, we see that there is an increase in melanoma brain
metastases with age,
and a decrease in
survival with those patients, again, with age.
We want to understand how these cells are getting to the brain in young and aged
patients, whether there's a dormancy component there as well, and to
see, again, how we can act like that little nun and target those changes in the
brain metastases. So this work is being done by two
individuals in my lab. The first is Cheyenne Palm, who's a PhD candidate.
She has been using some really fascinating techniques, including these really
cool ex vivo cultures where she plates melanoma
cells on brain sections that she
has isolated from young and aged mice.
And then she just takes genetically identical melanoma cells.
She plates them on these sections, and I hope what you can see
is that those melanoma cells, when plated on the
surface of a brain from a young mouse, don't invade
very much into that brain slice. But those same cells
plated on the brain slice from an aged mouse invade very
rapidly into the brain.
Kevin Zhang is a neuropathology fellow in the lab,
and he was really interested in these observations about
dormancy and time to metastases. He looked at his brain mets,
and he saw that
just like the lung mets,
those patients over the age of 60 will develop brain mets
much quicker than patients diagnosed with melanoma when they were under the age
of 60. So he wanted to know whether some of the same mechanisms that
we see that drive dormancy into the lung drive dormancy and
outgrowth in the brain as well. So he took melanoma cells that are
endogenously low in non-canonical Wnt signaling, as marked
by WNT5A. And the red cells are the melanoma cells,
and he sees that when they don't have a lot of WNT5A, they make
these sort of large outgrowing colonies in the brain.
These are the brain slices again. And when he
overexpresses WNT5A in these cells, they make these tiny little
colonies, just like we saw in the lung.
And if he treats them with an antagonist of WNT5A, like SFRP1,
he can cause these cells to now grow again in these larger outgrowing
metastases.
And this is just a quantification.
So that was really interesting.
And we were super excited because it seemed like in the brain metastases,
we were seeing what we had seen in the lung, which is that these WNT5A
high melanoma cells are playing this sort of dual role where they're critical for
dissemination to the lung or to the brain, but once they're there,
WNT5A needs to shut off for those cells to grow out.
However,
in order to think further about this, Kevin decided to implant
tumors directly into the brain rather than letting them invade
there from the heart or the skin. And what he saw was that
when he directly implants tumors into the brain, even those that
overexpress WNT5A will grow out very rapidly, even more so than the
control cells. So that caused us to pause for a minute and scratch
our
heads
and ourselves.
And
we started to think whether maybe there were
changes in the brain microenvironment.
So we know that in primary tumors from young and aged mice,
the tumors that are in the aged mice, again, these are genetically
identical tumor lines, just implanted into either
young or aged immunocompetent mice, well, the tumors in the aged mice
express a lot of WNT5A and fewer antigens like MITF, for
example. So,
we also know from previous work in the lab that this is
correlated to an increase in markers that
are involved in recruiting myeloid-derived suppressor
cells. And myeloid-derived suppressor cells themselves
are
very active producers of WNT5A in the tumor
microenvironment. So what we're trying to determine now is that
whether in these aged brain microenvironments, we're seeing an
immunosuppressive microenvironment.
And
the other thing that we noticed when we were looking at WNT5A patterns of
melanoma cells in the brain was that if the cells had high
WNT5A, they would move into the brain in very different manners.
So, in the first little movie, these are
melanoma cells in yellow, the green are the blood vessels, and the
melanoma cells are wrapped around the blood vessels if they have high
WNT5A. If they have moderate levels of WNT5A, they make these
little small colonies. They don't seem very associated with
the vasculature. And if they have very little or
no WNT5A, they make these large spheroidal outgrowing tumors,
and that's how they seem to get into the brain.
Sorry, this is just a quantification of all of that.
So what we're beginning to see is that tumors that have high WNT5A
tend to be very tightly associated with endothelial
cells and the vasculature.
And if we look at markers of endothelial cells, and
we know that the cells that have high WNT5A have receptors for these.
And Cheyenne recently showed
that the vasculature in the young and aged brain also looks very
different. So if you look at the two images on
your left, these are blood vessels stained in the brain from
young and aged naive mice. They don't have tumor.
And you can see that these vessels break down like crazy in the
aged brain. And when I saw this, I was like, "Yeah, no wonder I can't remember what
I came to the grocery store for," right?It's a little scary.
And when you add tumor into the skin, it causes even more of
this degradation of these blood vessels.
So we're currently using some whole brain imaging to look at the way these
blood vessels are behaving in the brain and how they
relate to the tumor cells as well. But if we go
back to our in vitro slices where we've put these tumor cells on brain
slices and we look more closely at how tumor cells are getting in in
the young and aged brain, I think you can see, just like we're seeing
in Kevin's work, Cheyenne is also seeing that these tumor cells wrap themselves
around the blood vessel to get into the
brain slices
when they are seated on young brain slices.
But on aged brain slices, they get in any old how.
If there are blood vessels to get in, great, they'll hop onto those, but
they don't seem to care, and those blood vessels are super
leaky.
So Kevin also decided to look at
proteomics of the endothelial cells in the
brain as compared to melanoma cells.
And what he found was that where he saw increased
adhesion molecules, he would see that in
invasive melanoma, there were increased expression of the receptors for
these molecules, including things like VCAM1.
He also sees increases in SFRP1, so we're trying to reconcile
that as well with the in vivo
intracranial data.
So I think overall, we're beginning to get this sort of
temporal
timeline of metastasis in melanoma, where we have
metastases that require non-canonical Wnt
signaling to leave the primary site and go to the lung, but
once they get there, they need to lose that WNT5A
in order to come out of dormancy and to grow.
And we're seeing that in the aged brain, there is also
the added component of the endothelial barriers.
The young brain microenvironment has an intact blood-brain barrier,
which favors a more perivascular type of invasion, which itself can be
driven by WNT5A. And in the aged brain microenvironment,
there's compromised vascular integrity, and we're currently doing
the spatial profiling to look at the immune microenvironments in those brains as
well.
So I get to come here and talk about the work, but these are the
amazing people who actually do the work.
Very lucky to have
had, and to still have, incredibly talented people in the lab,
wonderful collaborators at Johns Hopkins, across the country, and
across the world.
I will say, when I look out at this room, I just see so many incredible
friends and supporters. Today is a special day for me.
It's my 25th wedding anniversary, so I want to shout out.
Thank you. I want to give a shout-out to my biggest supporter, who
is sitting in the back of the room, and who has been the
collaborator on my favorite aging project, my daughter, Alina,
who is, by the way, probably the most highly decorated
AACR person ever to have existed.
I will be happy to take any questions.
Thanks, and congratulations, Ashy.
Thank you.
This is really cool. So I'm thinking as you're saying this, not
only we know that organ sites and the vasculature is different,
but organs age differently. So I'm wondering
if it's even worth a thought to try to look at
melanoma and metastasizing to different organs at different stages.
Like if you did lung slices the way you did your brain slices-
Right
... would you come up with different microenvironmental factors?
Or do you think that the
clonality, heterogeneity of the cells that metastasize
may be different or adapt differently to different
aging tissues?
Yeah.
If that's clear.
Yeah. That's a great question. So we have been looking at the differences
in young and aged lung compared to young and aged brain.
Some data that I was hoping would be ready to show you today that wasn't quite
ready is we've taken,
in collaboration with Julio Giargiso, we have tumor
cells that have implanted in the young and
aged lung, and then waited a few weeks, and then taken them
and done single cell sequencing. So we have the early stage and the late
stage.
And what we're looking for is actually things like neoantigens,
to see how those cells are dictating the tumor microenvironment.
I will say that when we're looking at the young and aged brain, they look
very similar in some of the secreted factors.
But it's interesting because in the aged brain, those are being secreted
more by glial cells than astrocytes, rather than
fibroblasts. But when we look at the young and aged lymph
nodes, it's almost the opposite to the lung.
And so it is really a great point. I think at some point, I need
to just sit down and maybe write a review of all of the
different changes in young and aged lymph node, young and aged lung, young and aged
brain, and Mitch is doing some beautiful work on liver as well.
Very cool. Thanks.
Thanks.
Ashy, that was beautiful, and congratulations also.
So the last part that you showed, the beautiful images
with the endothelial cells, do you see any changes in pericytes
there?
So I do get asked that a lot.
We have
not looked at pericytes as closely as we should have, is
the honest answer. Partly because melanoma cells are
so challenging. They already are wrapped around the blood
vessels.
They make a lot of markers that pericytes make.
And so it's been a little challenging to look at, and I really need to find a good
collaborator who knows their way around pericytes to
really figure that out.
Happy to collaborate.
Thank you.
All right. If there are no other questions, thank you so much.
If anyone is interested in the aging microenvironment, please come
to
a session in 6A, I think, at 2:30. I'm
chairing with Cosimo Commisso. So thank you
all.